ANDY RUDD: Hello, and welcome.
We're excited to have
you join us today
where we'll be sharing some
exciting ideas around enhancing
collaboration with Sheets,
Python, and Google Cloud
Platform.
I'm Andy Rudd, a product manager
with G Suite currently focused
on Google Sheets.
I'm joined today by
my colleague Anil
who is also a product manager
working on Google Cloud
Platform.
Anil and I and our teams
have been thinking a lot
about analytical collaboration.
And for many reasons,
collaboration is more important
now than it's ever been.
Sometimes, though,
and in particular when
it comes to complex
analysis, today's solutions
can be a bit tedious.
Often, this is because the
tools that we use and prefer
varies significantly from
job role to job role.
We've been working towards
more of an ideal solution.
And we're excited to give you
a sneak peek of that today.
From our point of view, an ideal
solution would do a few things.
It would allow anyone
in an organization
to be self-service to be
able to do the analysis they
need to do, regardless of
their technical proficiency.
It would allow common
analytical tasks and workflows
that a company uses
internally to be standardized.
And it might even allow the
most novices spreadsheet users
to leverage powerful
open source libraries
and cloud infrastructure
to get stuff done.
So with that said, the
solution that we'll show off
today would allow you to expose
Python-based custom functions
in Google Sheets.
These custom functions
are powered by GCP
serverless platform
product, Cloud Run.
With the serverless
model, users would not
have to deal with
managing infrastructure.
And they would only pay when
their functions are run.
So with that said,
today, we're going
to go through a few things.
What happens now will cover a
common analytical frustration
that we hear about in
companies all around the world.
We'll talk about
what could happen.
We'll show you a demo of
that tool actually in use.
And then we'll give
you a sneak peek
under the hood in the form of an
architectural overview of what
we've built so far.
And then we'll
give you some tips
for staying in the loop
to learn about what
we're up to, as we continue to
develop this product further.
So what happens today?
Let's take a look
at how collaboration
happens in companies all
around the world today.
Let's enter an
alternate universe
if you'll allow us where Anil
and I are still colleagues.
But this time, we work at
a company called Altostrat.
Altostrat is a
packaged foods company
that specializes in sweet
snacks in particular.
Andy is a business
analyst there.
And he is often responsible
for aggregating key business
metrics, delivering
presentations
to leadership to give you
the latest updates on KPIs.
Anil is a data scientist.
He has a background
in statistics.
And he is most
comfortable/happiest when
he is programming in Python.
They have worked on some
projects over the years.
But they do not know
each other that well.
It's often been more of a
give than a take with Andy
firing off last-minute requests
for some late breaking analysis
that leadership has asked for.
They were both comfortable
with G Suite communication
tools, chat, and email.
But Andy is more comfortable
in a spreadsheet.
He's familiar with the
traditional productivity
suite of tools.
Anil is familiar with
cloud infrastructure.
He likes to reprogram in IDD,
the code editor of his choice.
And one more thing.
Lately, Altostrat has been
thinking about how they could
re-evaluate their existing
suppliers of two key
ingredients-- sugar and flour--
unsurprising, based on
what they're known for--
and how they might consider
other suppliers in order
to keep their costs
down and maybe also be
more flexible and responding
to demand planning
exercises that come
up in the future.
So let's go inside a
recent Friday morning
when Andy and Anil's
paths crossed.
This will all start when
Ellen, who manages the Business
Analysis Unit at
Altostrat, is thinking
about what needs to be prepared
for an upcoming leadership
review.
So let's say the next Monday--
that's one business day away--
there is a 2, 3 wrap
up report that's
being delivered to Altostrat's
executive leadership.
Ellen and Andy have
talked about, offline,
some of the things that
might go into that report.
And they've determined
that he should be
responsible for a few things.
Summarizing last quarter
sales, that sort of always
implicit in this report.
But also doing analysis around
this discussion about supplier
analysis.
So looking at the
suppliers that exist now,
looking at other
suppliers in the market,
which Ellen and Andy have
collected some data on.
And then looking at how
the various output in price
of those two key ingredients
could affect Altostrat's bottom
line.
There's many downstream
implications of this decision.
It will go into their overall
production capacity planning.
It will help them have
better revenue estimates.
And it may even feed
into their price
modeling for their
products in the future.
So Ellen kicks us
off with an email.
She says, Andy, on Monday,
we've got this presentation.
Let's make sure that we
deliver that supplier analysis
we talked about.
I'd like you to reach out
to the data science team
and get that model.
Andy says, of course, I'm on it.
So it looks like he's going to
take some of the inputs they've
collected, work with
the data science team
to revise a model that maybe
they've done in the past,
and then update it with new
supplier capacity information.
So Andy knows who to go to and
he has a question like this.
He reached out to Anil.
And he says, hey, it
is that time again.
Lucky you.
Can we please remodel
Altostrat's output,
given some of the
new information
on suppliers that
we've collected?
Also, sure.
Of course.
I think I sort of
remember us doing
something similar to this a
quarter or a few quarters ago.
Let me try to find that
model that I developed.
And we'll run it with the new
inputs that you have attached.
So maybe Anil's not
expecting this request today.
But he's going to
make time for it.
He'll have to find this model
that he's written in the past
and update it with
new information.
Before he digs in,
though, he's going
to check in with his team to
baseline on other requests
that they have on
their plate today.
So Greta is another data
scientist at Altostrat.
Anil messages, her.
And he says a little gloomily,
hey, another request just
came in from the
Business Analysis Team.
Another one, she says.
What are they looking
for this time?
Anil says, the
product optimization
with new suppliers.
Greta remembers Anil walking her
through this model in the past.
And she says, hey,
you know what.
Let me take on the FP&A
request that we also
have going on our plate today.
And you enjoy this one.
Take it on yourself.
Anil is a little
frustrated here, maybe.
But we know there's
a lot on his plate.
But he's going to
get the job done.
So first things first.
Anil starts to look
in his local computer
to determine when he did
this analysis previously.
He's going to track it down.
It's always a
little bit tedious.
He has to think about when
the last time a question
or request like this came in.
What he named the model.
What he named the file,
including the Python code when
he last developed this.
It's always not quite as
humorless as it should be.
So that's fine and well.
But, unfortunately, a little
while later, Andy realizes
he left out some key inputs.
This time to get Anil's
attention more quickly,
he sends a chat.
He says, hey, I
forgot one more thing.
Anil's starting to respond.
The frustration is mounting.
Let's see what
this is all about.
Andy says, hey, I left
out our current supplier.
What a stupid silly mistake.
And so I've just passed along
updated capacity information
to you.
Anil says, of course,
hey, that's fine.
No worries.
I'll be sure to
include those as well.
So what does this mean?
Anil still has a few morning
meetings to get through.
But once he gets
back to the model,
he'll turn his attention
to Andy's request.
He'll think about combining the
now two disparate inputs that
have been provided and then
providing his results back
to Andy in some fashion.
So Andy's asked for
a few things before.
But Anil has now found
the model that we
care about this time around.
What do we want to do?
We want to determine Altostrat's
potential product output, given
a number of different suppliers
with different information.
They can provide key ingredients
in different quantities
and prices.
We get a sneak peak here of the
model that Anil has developed.
It looks pretty cool.
There's some awesome
things happening.
He's using some popular Python
libraries, like SciPy and NumPy
to do this optimization.
Anil's working in the local
code editor of his choice.
He might tweak some
of the logic as he
goes to make improvements
that are easy.
He'll swap in the
new inputs that
have been provided by Andy.
And then, unfortunately, Andy
is very scared, very intimidated
by any sign of code whatsoever.
So he can't just share
his Python notebook.
But what he'll do
instead is once he's
happy with the results
that have been generated,
he'll output a CSV file that
can be more easily consumed.
With that done, Anil will
turn to Google Sheets,
which is a well-understood tool
medium often used at Altostrat.
An innovative, collaborative
productivity, Sheets
is known as a great way
to share an analysis
throughout the company.
So a while later, Anil's
happy with his results.
He imports that CSV we talked
about into Google Sheets,
and he shares it away.
He wants to give Andy an update.
So he sends a message.
He says, hey, I just shared you
a spreadsheet with the results.
Some time passes.
But Andy says, oh,
thank you so much.
We're well on our way.
Is there anything interesting?
And here, Anil's
saying, that's really
where your expertise comes in.
You tell me, we've generated
some cool business insights.
What I care about
is I made my model
a little better along the way.
Andy doesn't have time
to look right now.
But based on his work
with Anil in the past,
he trusts that the
outputs here are sound.
So a few hours have passed.
Andy's been a bit distracted.
But results at hand, he
shares the output with them.
He fires off an email.
Hey, the data scientist
team turned around
that analysis we asked for.
Optimization is herein.
I have linked to you a Google
Sheet containing the results.
What do you think?
Ellen says, that looks good.
But you know what.
I've been thinking about this.
And often in the past,
our executive team
has asked them
questions on the fly.
They've wanted to
know maybe, what
if we got our suppliers
to reduce their proposed
prices by 10%?
Let's plan for that
scenario as well.
That's a reasonable request.
But it's going to shift
Andy into a different gear.
It's getting late.
Remember, the aim was
to wrap up this analysis
by the end of the day.
So rapidly, he writes
another email to Anil.
I hate to do this on
a Friday afternoon.
We've all gotten this message.
But I need a minor tweak.
Can we rerun that model
assuming a 10% price reduction?
Hearing nothing, he chats
Anil a few minutes later.
He says, hey, I just
wanted to check.
Did you see my email?
Still nothing-- another ping.
Hey, is that something
that we could reasonably
get done by the end of the day?
And then in a last ditch
attempt, it's almost 5 o'clock.
He says, hey, Anil, are
you even still around?
Unfortunately, it seems
like Anil has taken off.
He thought he got the job done.
He's off to the beach for
an early weekend, right?
So what happened here?
Some really good things
occurred along the way.
There's amazing tools.
Sheets was clutch
in this workflow
to share analysis quickly.
The communication
was pretty clear.
Anil was comfortable
in the programming
tools of his choice.
We had incredible
domain experts.
Everyone knew at each
step exactly what
they were looking for.
And we knew that we were
asking and answering
the right business
questions along the way.
And the analysis that
actually got generated
was pretty cool, right?
We're leveraging some
awesome open-source libraries
to generate results
specific to our company.
But there were some speed bumps.
The fact that
individuals along the way
were using different
toolkits made things
maybe a little bit more
arduous than they needed to be.
There were resource constraints.
It's clear that data
scientists at Altostrat
have a lot of inbound requests.
And maybe not enough
folks to answer them.
And Andy was certainly
not self-service
as far as the
scenario played out.
I think maybe some of these
pain points in particular
have been even exacerbated
over the last few months
when so many of us have
been working from home.
Maybe you've been feeling that
in your organization as well.
So what could happen?
We think that there
is a better way.
And we think that that path
could start in Google Sheets.
Why?
We saw in the
scenario that Sheets
is approachable from most
folks within a company.
It's universal.
It is collaborative.
And it's very easy to share
quick results and get feedback.
So what if instead,
though, Andy had
been able to tap into
the power of Python--
some of the libraries that Anil
used that we had talked about?
What if he could have accessed
the standardized optimization
calculation that
Altostrat runs by himself?
And what if he could have easily
leveraged cloud infrastructure
to get really powerful, big
data results really quickly?
Let's revisit that scenario with
some of these new possibilities
in mind.
So just like last time, this
all starts on a Friday morning
when Ellen sends her request.
She says, hey, we've
got this Monday review
coming up with the executives.
Let's turn around
that supplier analysis
that we had talked about.
Andy, again, says
sounds good to me.
This time around,
though, he might
be able to manage some of this
complex analysis by himself.
So imagine that in this
world, the data scientist
team at Altostrat has developed
some Altostrat-specific custom
functions that are
written in Python
and then made available to
many folks in the company
through Google Sheets.
Andy might start by
creating a new spreadsheet.
He might drop in the raw data
from the various suppliers
that he and Ellen have
collected information on.
And then he might
type ahead in the cell
as he would with
any native Sheets
function to see what sort
of analysis he could do.
So here, it looks like
Altostrat has named their custom
functions really well.
We have this well-named
spaced format
that they're using to
indicate what sort of analysis
they can do.
There are some cool
things available.
We see maybe a revenue
forecast custom function that
is standardized and available.
We see a supply/demand
forecasting
function, et cetera, et cetera.
So Andy will browse this list.
He'll look for the
sort of custom analysis
that he knows he needs
to do, and he'll call it.
So here, he found one called
OPSTRAT OPTIMIZE production.
He will pass through
that raw data
that he dumped in as
arguments into that function.
And he will hit Enter.
Just like that, he now
has results in the Sheet
that are doing this sort of
convex optimization based
on the raw inputs that we have
on the various suppliers we're
analyzing.
So he got this done
pretty quickly.
If we look at our
timestamps this time around,
we turned this around in
the course of half an hour.
And so he shares the spreadsheet
that he's created with Ellen.
Says, hey, I ran our
optimization model.
We looked at all of our
candidates suppliers.
And here are some of the
initial outputs in the Sheet.
What do you think?
So the iterative
cycle of noodling
is much faster this time around.
Ellen, likewise, says, hey,
this looks pretty good.
But we've gotten
a lot of questions
in the past about,
what if we can
push these guys on their
prices a little bit better.
I want to be prepared for those.
Let's rerun this with
that 10% price reduction.
So this time around, Andy simply
goes back to his spreadsheet
where he's done that
initial analysis.
He tweets some of the
underlying raw data
to reflect a 10% price
reduction across the suppliers
that we're looking at.
And then he calls that
Python-based custom
function once again in Sheets
to reflect the modified outputs.
So is that a new column?
He calls our function.
He enters the function and,
voila, in a new column,
he's done this scenario analysis
with 10% reduction in mind.
He comes back to his
boss, and he says, hey.
He's excited, right?
He's self-service
this time around.
He shares his results with
Ellen in the same spreadsheet.
He says, I did this scenario
planning really quickly.
And you know what.
Even if the executives want
to tweak that 10% figure
on the fly on
Monday, we can do it.
We can do it in the meeting.
It'll be live.
It'll be great.
It's pretty quick.
Ellen's excited.
She says perfect.
Sounds like we're
ready for anything.
So that was a much
more efficient flow
this time around.
Let's jump to a real demo of
the tool that we've developed
and see it in action.
ANIL DHAWAN As
you've been seeing,
I've been helping Andy answer
his questions from the business
slide.
Let's now take a look
at how Andy and I
achieve this ideal workflow
he just showed you.
We begin by looking at the
sheet that Andy and I maintain
together-- call that
Production Optimization.
Here, we're looking at
Altostrat's baked goods
division.
And what that
division does is we
have a series of factories that
can produce donuts and muffins.
Our goal is to figure out the
optimal number of packages
of donuts and muffins we
should be making in our factory
so that we can maximize revenue
based on each supplier's
supply of our key ingredients--
in this case, flour and sugar.
You can see that
Andy has already
given me a list of eight
different suppliers
with their quantities.
You can also see
that I've already
started to work on this model
by filling out two of these rows
and providing two
of those answers.
But I still have
a long ways to go.
So how did I come up
with these answers?
Well, being a data scientist,
I mostly work in Python.
So what I've done is I've
built some Python code
that, as a trained
model, I can figure out
based on these quantities
of flour/sugar what
these ideal production
targets should
be along with the revenue
we're maximizing against.
Let's take a look
at that code now.
I'm going to switch
over to my code editor.
And we see my Python
function here.
I call it Optimize Production.
It takes in two
parameters-- the amount
of flour available-- the
amount of sugar available.
And what this code does is it
uses SciPy and NumPy to execute
a linear programming
technique that can figure out
the optimal production targets
that we need in our factories.
Let's take a deeper
look at the code now.
You can see that we're starting
by fetching some prices
and fetching some
material specs.
And then we're
populating some values
that we need to pass into the
linear programming library.
And then we're returning
a solution that we /
If we look at some of
the helper function,
you can see that we're actually
getting prices lie from a sales
pricing database.
It's really cool, because
it allows the sales
team to go ahead and update
those prices if they need to
and have those changes
reflected in our model anytime.
You can also see
that our material
specs are being fetched from
another table in a database.
This is also great.
Should we change our recipe for
how we make muffins and donuts,
well, those changes would
be reflected here as well.
So great.
We see that I have
some Python code that's
implemented this model.
And I've been testing this.
And I'm feeling
pretty good about it.
Now, what I really
want to do is move
to a more self-service
model with Andy.
I'd love to expose this
function directly to Andy
so that he can call
it inside Sheets.
The way I do that is I begin
by creating a manifest.
This manifest describes to
Sheets how this very functions
should be exposed to Andy so
you can call it from a sheet
directly.
This manifest is
pretty straightforward.
We first define a
namespace, which
is just a way of grouping
a set of functions.
Next, I define each of the
functions I wish to expose.
In this case, I
have one, and it's
called Optimize Production.
I also provide a bunch of
helper text that will help Andy
and other callers understand
how to invoke my function.
Next, I describe the argument.
As we've been
seeing, my function
takes in two parameters--
the amount of flour
available and the amount
of sugar available.
And each of those is a number.
Finally, my function
returns a list
we call a range of
numbers that correspond
to the number of donut
packages, muffin packages,
and the amount of
revenue we will receive
if we produce those quantities.
So great.
I have functioning Python code.
And I have a manifest
that describes
how my code should be exposed.
I got one last step
before I can deploy here.
I populate a
requirements.txt file
so that I can capture any
of the external dependencies
I might have in this code.
In this case, I
rely on the SciPy,
NumPy packages along
with a MySQL connector.
Great.
Now, let's take a
look at how I actually
expose this function to Sheets.
To do that, I run a
tool called Sheets DF.
Sheets DF allows me
to deploy my code
and along with the manifest
and have that function be
exposed inside Sheets.
So want to go ahead
and invoke that here.
What this code will do
in just under a minute
is go ahead and deploy my Python
code into Google Cloud Platform
and wire that up into the sheet.
Let's turn our attention
now to the sheet
and see how that works.
You can see on the
right-hand side,
I have a new add on
that's been populated.
Let's take a look at that.
I click here.
And I see on the right
sidebar my function
that I've exposed called
Altostrat.optimizeproduction.
And you can see here that all
of that helper text I wrote
is showing up.
And what this tells us is
that we can invoke a function
called
Altostrat.optimizeproduction.
We're passing two arguments--
the amount of flour
available, sugar available.
And it will return to us a
tuple of donuts, muffins,
and revenue.
So now let's now
take a look at how
I can invoke this custom
function implemented
in Python inside my sheet.
So let's take one of these
other suppliers for which I
haven't worked on yet.
And let's try
invoking my function.
So I'm going to go ahead and
invoke this function just
like any of the
built-in function
just by typing the name.
So here, we'll
start the Altostrat.
And you can see that I
get some autocompletions.
So I click this.
And it looks like it needs
the amount of flour available.
So that's available
in this cell.
Next, it needs the amount
of sugar available.
So let's go to this cell.
And I can go ahead and
invoke this function.
What this is now doing is
calling my Python code,
running my model,
and returning result.
You can see here that based
on this quantity of flour
and sugar, my model just
turned these values.
Now, this is great because I can
call it directly from a sheet.
And because I'm in a sheet,
I can do all the cool things
I typically do in a sheet.
For example, I can erase
these hardcoded values.
And I can simply
drag my formula up.
And you can see that it will
do the same computation calling
my Python code
this time instead.
I can also finish answering
the rest of the question
that Andy is posturing
by dragging down.
And you can see here
that we have populated
entire table of results.
You could also imagine that
if Andy comes again and wants
to add a new supplier--
let's say supplier nine.
And that supplier can produce,
let's say, 600 units of flour
and 200 years of sugar.
And he can simply
copy down this formula
and have this invoke
the same Python code
and model to come up with a
new forecast of production.
You can see that right here.
Because we're in
Sheets, we can also
take advantage of the rest
of Sheets functionality.
For instance, let's say
I wanted to figure out
which supplier is going to
give us the most revenue.
Well, I can merely
ask Sheets about that.
So I can say, supplier
with maximum revenue.
You can see here that
Sheets is telling us
that that supplier is going
to be supplier number four.
And it optimizes
revenue at $17,750.
Great.
We've just seen how this
workflow looks in action.
Let's take a look now behind
the scenes to see how it works.
There are two scenarios here.
One is I as a developer wanting
to expose these functions
to Andy in Sheets.
Let's see how that works.
I start by creating my Python
code locally on my machine.
And I use the tool
we've created,
Sheet CF, to deploy that
package into Google Cloud.
Well, what's really
happening behind the scenes
is we are creating a
container image that
will get deployed into Google
Cloud Platform's serverless
product Cloud Run.
So we have some source
code on my machine.
And we have Cloud Run,
which expects a container.
So we're going to have to figure
out a way to build a container.
That's actually
what Sheet CF does.
First thing it
does, actually, when
you run it is create a container
image using Google Cloud's
manage servers
called Cloud Build.
Cloud Build takes a
description of a set of tasks
and a formal of how to create a
container image as some source
code.
It executes those tasks and
stores those container images
into Google's
Container Registry.
So this is automated
with a Sheet CF deploy.
Great.
So now we've gone from
source code to a container.
And that container now lives
in the Container Registry.
The next step is to create
a deployment in Cloud
Run of that very container.
So that's what happens next.
When Cloud Run
gets that request,
it goes to the
Container Registry,
pulls down the container,
runs it locally,
and exposes an end
point on the internet.
Finally, we secure that end
point so only the G Suite
infrastructure can invoke it.
And we expose an add-on for Andy
to be used inside of Sheets.
So great.
That's how it looks like
for me as an author.
Now, what's happening
when Andy is actually
invoking these
functions on his machine
inside of Google Sheets?
So that workflow
looks like this.
We start with Andy
using Google Sheets.
And, of course,
since we've already
deployed this end
point in Cloud Run,
we have that running in GCP.
So Andy fires up a
sheet, picks up a cell,
and enters a
function invocation.
In this case, he's calling the
optimize production function.
What this does
behind the scenes is
the Sheets knows that
this function is actually
implemented by a
Cloud Run endpoint.
It goes ahead and
takes that information,
converts it into
an HTTP request,
sends that over to Cloud Run.
Cloud Run then looks at my
container and executes it.
As we saw, the source code
running in my container
was a series of Python that
use a cloud SQL and cloud
storage to gather his results.
Once my function
is done executing,
it returns those results in
the form of an HTTP response.
Sheets then takes
that and shares
that with Andy in the form of
displaying it inside his sheet.
So you can see here the power of
Google Cloud Platform is masked
completely behind the scenes.
And all Andy needs
to see is Sheets.
But my code running
in Google Cloud
has been containerized
for me automatically.
And in doing so, I have access
to a variety of cloudy PIs
and the full power Python.
So what can you do with
this type of thing?
Well, we see several
key use cases.
The first is the one
we've been talking about,
which is collaborating
across teams and rules.
Andy is on the business side.
I'm a data scientist.
Sure, we used to
use Sheets already.
But I was really copying
and pasting results
and maybe loading up
a CSV occasionally.
Now, in this new workflow,
we can actually collaborate
in a self-service fashion.
The next is exposing
proprietary calculations.
How many times have
we all seen situations
where we take a spreadsheet
with some calculations.
We make a copy of it to tweak
some of those calculations.
And all of a sudden, we lose
our single record of truth.
Imagine this happening
throughout your enterprise.
Imagine how many variations
of some basic calculation
are now running around
in your organization.
Well, with this
kind of model where
you centralize the functions
inside of a Python module
and expose that
through these atoms,
the business can
continue maintaining
the integrity of
those calculations
and update them
whenever they're needed.
What ends up happening
is the business
will always pick up the
latest and greatest results.
And there's no worry
about spreadsheet drift.
Another is accessing
multiple custom data sources.
We already saw this
with my Python code,
which was using cloud
storage as well as cloud SQL.
You might have custom
other data sources
that might be on GitHub
or other locations.
And because we're running in
a containerized environment
with Cloud Run, you have
access to all of them.
Another is calling cloud APIs.
Because most Google Cloud APIs
have a robust client library,
it becomes very, very
easy to consume them
from my Python code.
And the fact that I can marry
the results of that into Sheets
makes this a very, very
compelling situation.
For example, I might
use Google Cloud
to translate APIs
or machine learning
APIs to autotrain a model.
And all of a sudden, I
can stitch those together
and expose them to the business
in the form of a spreadsheet.
And finally, Python
is what's powering
all of this under the hood.
And Python, as you
might be aware,
is full of hundreds of
great complex packages that
make sure that you do not
have to start from scratch.
In fact, I use NumPy and SciPy
to do a linear programming
system inside of my code.
It was very easy to do in
under 100 lines of code.
So great.
What have we seen today so far?
We've seen that in today's
world, collaborating
across the business,
across experts,
regular organization
is a challenge.
And Sheets already
plays a key role.
The opportunity we
see is for Sheets
to play an even greater
role and for the business
to be able to expose functions
to the rest of the organization
through some
standardized interfaces.
And what that means
is folks like Andy
can self-service
those calculations.
And I can spend
more time focusing
on my nights and weekends.
We're excited about
this approach.
And we welcome you to
learn more about it
and try it out for yourself.
You can do so by signing
up on this form link
below where you'll get notified
when this was made available.
We're really excited to hear
what you might do with this
and hear the kinds
of scenarios that
might be applicable
in your organization.
And on behalf of Andy,
we'd like to thank you
for watching this presentation.